welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
boss and I'm excited to partner with
Spotify to bring you this breakdown of
episode one of the Riddler secrets in
the dark the new audio Thriller and
don't forget that new rockstars is three
channels so make sure you're subscribed
to the Deep dive and the break room to
maximize your intake of Pop Culture
analysis and if you want to support the
channel head over to nerd rot. shop pick
up some sweet merch and show off your
nerdy fandom while you're wandering the
streets of Gotham City or wherever you
live that hopefully has way less
villains okay secrets in the dark
follows the Riddler played by Hassan
Minaj this version of the character last
heard in the Spotify podcast series
Batman unburied is actually a reluctant
Ally to the bat family helping out
Barbara Gordon and Alfred through the 10
episodes of that series Minaj has said
that the series will be equally
surprising because instead of the Batman
saving the Riddler Batman needs the
Riddler to help save the bat from
certain death and this time finally The
Riddler gets the spotlight that he
deserves we open in the iconic DC local
Arkham Asylum the Elizabeth Arkham
Asylum for the criminally insane was
first introduced in Batman 258 and has
since been featured in TV films video
games and now in this immersive audio
Thriller you're really going to want to
listen on your best headphones because
the immersive audio makes you feel like
you are really in one of the cells among
Batman's Rogues Gallery we open
fittingly enough with the Riddler Dro in
a riddle what disappears the moment you
say its name lights out the answer
is silence and to that redler we get the
hilarious response more of the
man all the cells in Arkham and I
ended up next to your American ass these
gripes are coming out of whan Jones AKA
Killer Croc played here by Payton Crim
that halfman half crocodile villain was
introduced in 1983 and Batman 357 the
Ridler mentions that it was no accident
that the two ended up next to each other
if you've ingested any stories featuring
The Riddler you know that this guy is
all about playing the long game and this
version of the character is no exception
during a cell inspection nigma lets it
be known that he's keeping tabs on all
the guards at Arkham and this must be
Oscar Ramirez of Philadelphia recently
moved to Gotham for his exciting new
career and institutional Corrections
what I love how nigma cheerfully recites
facts like this knowing full well it
comes off as a threat the head guard
sends the Newbie away and hands nigma a
letter from the outside we learn that
nigma has been bribing the guard to get
Contraband from the outside the letter
is from Julian day AKA calendar man
played here by Hugh Scott the character
dates back all the way to 1958 when he
made his debut in Detective Comics
Number 2 59 the character had a small
cameo in James gun to Suicide Squad
played in that movie by his brother sha
gun we learned from calender man's
letter that he has been transferred to
the comparatively cushy Gotham
rehabilitation center but all is not
well calendar man writes someone's
watching me here not the guards shadows
in the Halls Wings flapping outside my
window someone is coming for me I can
hear the calendar louder than ever
before Shadows Wings sounds like
Gotham's favorite heavily armored orphan
but this is a mystery star in the
Riddler so I'm guessing this is going to
go a lot deeper our next scene is a
group therapy session that the Riddler
has weasel his way into leading the
other participants are Killer Croc and
perhaps the most amazing character that
could possibly pop up King Tutt this
character was introduced in the 1966
Batman TV series at starred Adam West he
was an egyptologist who believes he's
The Reincarnation of King Tut he made
his way into the comics continuity in
2009's Batman confidential he's being
played here by a fantastically scenery
chewing aflamu Johnson you've come to
pay tribute to the Pharaoh toan common
son of the great God raw Killer Croc
mentions that the DC villain Sports
Master usually joins them but has
recently escaped this psychotic ex-
football player villain made his debut
in All-American Comics all the way back
in 1947 he's fought many members of the
bat family throughout the years and has
done some time as a member of The
Suicide Squad maybe he'll pop up in a
later episode the therapy set session is
interrupted by an Arkham guard who tells
nigma that he's going to be brought to
one of the processing rooms nigma
immediately suspects something is up he
drops into the riddle tossed in a coffin
measure by measure but I live again as
another man's treasure huh the answer is
trash specifically the human trash known
as detective Arnold flas Arnold flas is
a crooked cop who first popped up in
Batman 404 he's played here by Jim Fury
flash shows nigma a photo of a mutilated
corpse that he immediately
recognizes Jesus
that photo is that Julian all those guts
oh am I disrespecting your bestie's
memory his neck was broken too calendar
man has apparently been murdered I love
how the Riddler whom we previously only
heard is confident and glib is terrified
here by what he's seeing FL has a plan
to transfer nigma at Gotham City
rehabilitative the next day nigma
realizes that because this particular
facility is minimum security flas is
actually sending him to his death later
he's laying out what he saw to Killer
Croc he mentions that the photo of
Julian's body had broken glass ground
into the clothes as if he'd been dragged
through a window from a height nigma
theories that calender man was abducted
before he was murdered to solve the
mystery he must get access to gcpd
databases that means he and Killer Croc
Must Escape before morning nigma of
course has an Escape Plan ready to go
having memorized the key shapes from
every guard he's constructed lockpicks
to all the cells on their way out
Ramirez the new Guard from the beginning
of the episode draws his gun on them
only to be pistol whipped by the other
Arkham guards who are on nigma's payroll
yeah he's been playing a very very long
long game The Riddler and Croc Escape in
a van that the Riddler has stashed
because of course he had a van stash he
plans to sit outside gcpd and hack into
their Network when Croc asks if he's
worried about getting caught he replies
the police won't even know I'm there the
fools know my name but very few in this
city know my face if I'm not wearing a
suit covered in question marks I'm just
another brown man to them the files he
downloads have a chilling suggestion
that calender man was murdered by none
other than the Batman and with that
insane Cliffhanger the episode ends yes
all the evidence seems to be pointing to
Batman being the killer but Batman
historically has had a stringent no
killing policy so has Bruce gone off the
deep end or is it someone trying to
frame him we know Sports Master is on
the loose and would be a shocking twist
for this brutal crime to be penetrated
by a villain that's historically been
kind of a punchline could it be crooked
members of the gcpd or another member of
Batman's Gallery if you have any
predictions let us know in the comments
down below can't wait to hear how this
mystery unfolds I'm Eric boss thank you
so much and remember to subscribe to new
rockars I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye